[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen
dieses freitags
umstrittene Hilfe aus Washington die USA
werden wohl Streu Munition an die
Ukraine liefern
Ende eines schweren Justiz Irrtums
Manfred genditzky saß 13 Jahre
unschuldig im Gefängnis jetzt ist er ein
freier Mann
und überzeugend in Runde drei Alexander
Zverev siegt weiter auf dem heiligen
Rasen von Wimbledon
[Applaus]
seit fast 500 Tagen tobt der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine tötet
täglich Menschen verschlingt Unmengen an
Munition und Waffen mit ihrer
Gegenoffensive kommt die Ukraine kaum
voran jetzt wollen die USA offenbar
Streubomben liefern dieser Munitionstyp
wird von vielen Ländern geächtet denn
Streubomben setzen unzählige kleine
Sprengsätze frei viele davon explodieren
erst später und können noch lange nach
ihrem Abwurf Menschen töten oder
verletzen ein internationales Abkommen
ratifiziert von Deutschland und 109
weiteren Ländern verbietet den Einsatz
von Streumunition doch weder die USA
noch Russland oder die Ukraine sind
dabei Christian von Rechenberg berichtet
Streu Munition im Einsatz sie verteilt
Geschosse über weite Flächen zerstört
was sie in den Weg kommt ohne
Unterschied lange hatte die Ukraine
gedrängt nun wollen die USA die
hochumstrittene und international
geächtete Streumunition liefern Kritik
hält sich in Grenzen
wird bereits im Krieg in der Ukraine
eingesetzt und zwar von beiden Seiten
der Unterschied ist dass Russland
Streumunition einsetzt um die Ukraine
anzugreifen und die Ukraine setzt die
Streumunition ein um sich gegen einen
zwei weitere Gründe sprechen laut
Experten für den Einsatz von
Streumunition zum einen sei diese Waffe
besser geeignet die russischen
Verteidigungslinien effektiv zu treffen
zum zweiten haben die Verbündeten der
Ukraine Probleme mit dem Nachschub an
konventioneller Munition
wir haben mehrere Varianten von
Streumunition in unserem Beständen und
die die wir in Betracht ziehen würden
keine älteren Varianten umfassen die
mehr als 2,35% Blindgänger beinhalteten
die Blindgänger machen diese Munition
neben der brachialen Streuung so
gefährlich wird Zivilisten Bilder aus
dem Vietnamkrieg von Streumunition und
ihren Opfern 110 Staaten haben im
sogenannten Oslo Abkommen
einsatzherstellung und Weitergabe dieser
Munition verboten
Deutschland hatte die Konvention
ebenfalls unterzeichnet für uns ist das
keine Option die Länder die sich dieser
Konvention nicht angeschlossen haben und
dazu gehört neben China Russland die
Ukraine und die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika das habe ich nicht zu
kommentieren die USA sind entschlossen
die offizielle Bestätigung steht noch
aus
immer
glauben die US-Experten dass die Ukraine
mit Streubomben diesen Krieg für sich
entscheiden kann
das erhält jedenfalls die Chance auf
einen Sieg sagt man hier in Washington
weil die Streubomben das beste Mittel
sein um die tief eingegrabenen
russischen Stellungen an der Front zu
überwinden außerdem sagt man hier das
sei alternativlos weil schlicht und
ergreifend die herkömmliche Munition
bald aufgebraucht sein könnte Lieferung
und Produktion lassen offenbar zu
wünschen übrig es gibt einfach nicht
genug deswegen hat der Präsident grünes
Licht gegeben die USA haben
Lagerbestände von 4,7 Millionen Stück
Streumunition und offenbar war das Ganze
gut vorbereitet denn es liegen bereits
10.000 Stück dieser Munition in Europa
parat könnten gleich weitergegeben
werden und man hat sich offenbar auch
mit den Verbündeten auf die gleiche
Linie verständigt die schon bei
Kampfpanzern und Kampfflugzeugen galt
eben jede Regierung entscheidet für sich
alleine was sie jeweils an Waffen
liefert trotzdem könnte diese
Entscheidung nächste Woche beim
Nato-Gipfel natürlich noch für heftige
Diskussionen sorgen
wichtige Informationen aus Washington
vielen Dank hier wissen
was könnte die Streumunition militäre
springen darüber reden die Kollegen von
heute live mit einem Experten ab 19:30
Uhr auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
oder in der ZDF heute App und dort haben
wir auch noch weitere Aspekte zu dieser
umstrittenen Munition vertieft etwa auch
die Frage wie die geplanten Lieferungen
an die Ukraine gerechtfertigt werden
nach Deutschland zur letzten Sitzung des
Bundestags vor der Sommerpause da zeigte
sich wie blank manchen Nerven liegen
eigentlich hätte heute ja das
umstrittene heizungsgesetz verabschiedet
werden sollen doch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Schritt ja am
Mittwoch ein und verlangte mehr Zeit für
die Abgeordneten eine Steilvorlage für
die Opposition Ines Trumps über eine
hitzige Debatte
tumultartiges Szenen im Bundestag als
CDU und CSU den abwesenden
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
herbeizitieren wollen beschimpft ein
SPD-Mann die Union und das Präsidium er
muss nun ein Ordnungsgeld von 1000 €
zahlen statt der Verabschiedung des
heizungsgesetzes heute im Plenum eine
Debatte zum Verfahren Kritik am großen
Zeitdruck sie haben in den letzten 18
Monaten dieses Parlament
zum einem Ort der debattenverweigerung
und zu einem Ort des durchpeitschens von
Gesetzen gemacht wie der Fraktionschef
der Union will auch die Linke das Gesetz
nochmals überarbeiten wenn sie jetzt
sagen so wie das Gesetz ist wird es
verabschiedet ehrlich gesagt das ist
wieder eine Missachtung des
Verfassungsrecht es kann doch sein dass
außer Opposition sogar von uns aus der
Union Vorschläge kommen die sinnvoll
sind nicht das friss oder stirbt das ist
das falsche rangehen Applaus für die
Linken von der Union die Ampel dagegen
im Verteidigungsmodus das was sie letzte
Woche an Änderungen vorgelegt habe wäre
sehr wohl in der verfügbaren Zeit zu
bewältigen gewesen sie
versuchen 30.06 herumgesendet haben als
ob das quasi ein neuer Gesetzentwurf
gewesen sei als ob wir den alten ersetzt
hätten durch einen neuen das ist falsch
im Bundesrat versucht sich Minister
Harbeck der weil in Optimismus das
Gesetz steht und alle haben das gestern
noch mal bekräftigt also ja der Weg
dahin war doch nicht und steinig aber er
ist beschritten worden und auch das ein
Beispiel dafür dass sie ein schwieriges
Gesetz jetzt der Verabschiedung sehr
sehr nahe steht er könnte sich
verschätzen eine ruhige Sommerpause ohne
heizungsgesetz Debatte scheint alles
andere als sicher
weiter im Thema Energie auf der Insel
Rügen soll das nächste lng-terminal
entstehen das hat der Bundestag
entschieden ein weiterer Schritt weg vom
russischen Erdgas hinzu verflüssigem Gas
das per Schiff nach Deutschland kommen
soll
LNG terminals in Betrieb gibt es bereits
in Wilhelmshaven Brunsbüttel und Lubmin
bis Ende des Jahres soll schade
dazukommen und dann auch der neue
Standort Mukran auf der Insel Rügen in
Vorpommern regt sich Widerstand aus
Sorge vor negativen Folgen für Umwelt-
fünfeinhalb Millionen Übernachtungen
zählte Rügen im letzten Jahr das könnten
bald weniger werden Hotelbesitzerin
Johanna Schewe erlebt täglich dass Ihre
Gäste nach den lng-plänen Fragen und
verunsichert sind und wissen denn nicht
mehr warum sollen sie für ein Zimmer mit
direkt so viel Geld ausgeben wenn sie
denn doch wieder mit der Industrie
konfrontiert werden und mit diesen
politischen Themen
im Nordosten Rügens hier soll bis Ende
des Jahres das Import Terminal für
verflüssigtes Erdgas errichtet werden
über eine neu zu bauende 50 km lange
Pipeline soll das Gas nach Lubmin
gepumpt und in das deutsche Gas Netz
eingespeist werden der Bundestag hat das
LNG Beschleunigungsgesetz beschlossen
mokran ist hier als neuer Standort
aufgenommen die Gefahr einer Lage sein
noch nicht gebannt so der
Wirtschaftsminister
Lieferanten könnten ausfallen es kann zu
Anschlägen kommen es kann dazu kommen
dass Terminals nicht mehr funktionieren
es kann dazu kommen dass der Winter
kälter wird es kann dazu kommen das
Bevölkerung oder Industrie nicht wieder
so viel gaseinfahrt all das ist ja
möglich haben will auf Nummer sicher
gehen kritiker bezweifeln das weitere
lng-kapazitäten überhaupt gebraucht
werden am Nachmittag hat auch der
Bundesrat das Gesetz verabschiedet die
SPD geführte Landesregierung stellt sich
gegen die SPD geführte Bundesregierung
sie lehnt das Projekt ab befürchtet
Schaden für Umwelt und Tourismus und
sieht in LNG langfristig keine Zukunft
im Zentrum unserer Kritik steht dass der
Bund keine klaren Zusagen macht das
Mukran ein wasserstoffstandort wird und
dass das auch finanziert wird der
Gesetzgeber hat den Weg frei gemacht die
Gemeinde Binz auf Rügen hat bereits
angekündigt gegen das Projekt vor
Gericht zu ziehen
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel sollen
die Schiffe auf hoher See einen größeren
Beitrag leisten das hat sich die Welt
schifffahrtsorganisation vorgenommen und
sich neue Ziele gesetzt bis 2050 sollen
die Abgase schrittweise reduziert und
eine Umrüstung der weltweiten flotten
auf alternative Antriebe erreicht werden
umweltschützer kritisieren die Pläne als
Waage und unverbindlich die Schifffahrt
ist für fast drei Prozent der globalen
CO2 Emissionen verantwortlich
mehr Transparenz an der Fleischtheke das
soll ein neues staatliches
tierhaltungslabel bringen nach dem
Bundestag hat heute auch der Bundesrat
zugestimmt ab Januar gilt es
verpflichtend erst mal nur für frisches
Schweinefleisch aus Deutschland mit dem
Label ist auf einen Blick zu sehen wie
die Schweine gehalten wurden eingeteilt
in fünf Stufen vom mindeststandardstall
bis Bio später soll es auf verarbeitete
Produkte und andere Tierarten
ausgeweitet werden
schwere Krawalle und Proteste gegen
Polizeigewalt hielten Frankreich viele
Nächte lang in Atem Auslöser der Tod
eines Jugendlichen bei einer
Verkehrskontrolle erschossen durch einen
Polizisten mittlerweile ist wieder etwas
Ruhe eingekehrt in den bonius den sozial
benachteiligten vierteln und Vorstädten
von dort berichtet eine Brille
das ist wieder friedlich in tromplee
einer Pariser Vorstadt die brennenden
Autos sind lange gelöscht im
Jugendzentrum treffen wir junge Männer
die bereit sind mit uns zu reden über
ihre Wut den alltäglichen Rassismus
und auf der anderen Seite die Polizei es
gibt sicherlich auch gute Polizisten
aber man hat immer das Gefühl sie gegen
uns
der tote Junge Neil brennende Barrikaden
das ist nur ein Teil ihrer
Lebenswirklichkeit sagen sie
die Menschen die Medien die Polizei
sehen nur das Schlechte aber in den
Vorstädten gibt es mehr Gutes als
schlechtes das Leben in den borneliös
lässt sich gegenseitig zu helfen
Solidarität alle zusammen
mit Fördergeldern hat Trump Leon Park
umgestaltet mit großen Spielflächen
Bolzplätzen in der ganzen Region gibt es
Initiativen wir sind beim Job dating war
Gesa hat Fachabitur hofft jetzt auf
einen Job als Busfahrer
sie haben mir gesagt dass sie sich bald
wieder bei mir melden um weitere
persönliche Gespräche zu führen
eine Ausbildung ein Job wichtige Wege
aus der Unzufriedenheit glauben die
Veranstalter
Stadtteile in Schwierigkeiten geraten
ist zu sozialen Unruhen kommt dann gibt
es auch Partner die Lust haben mit uns
zu arbeiten und Dinge anzustoßen
es tut sich was zumindest hier merken
auch die Jugendlichen
ganz ehrlich man lebt gut den Trommler
es gibt gute Schulen gute Lehrer und vor
allem viele junge Menschen mit guten
Ideen und einem Überschuss an Energie
mit der sich hier auf ihre Zukunft
setzen
der Anschlag von Hanau mit neuen Toten
aus rassistischen Motiven hätte von der
Polizei nicht verhindert werden können
so verteidigte hessens Innenminister
Beuth heute die Arbeit der
Sicherheitsbehörden im Februar 2020 auf
der wohl letzten öffentlichen Sitzungen
des Hanau Untersuchungsausschusses
räumte Beuth zugleich Defizite ein vor
allem in der Kommunikation mit den
Opferfamilien die von den Angehörigen
erhoffte Entschuldigung des Ministers
gab es nicht Susanne Santina
viele Angehörige der Opfer des
rassistischen Anschlags von Hanau sind
seit 20 Monaten beim
Untersuchungsausschuss dabei in der
letzten öffentlichen Sitzung war Peter
Beuth geladen der als hessischer
Innenminister für die Polizei zuständig
ist befragt wurde er vor allem zum
Notruf der in der Tatnacht nachweislich
unterbesetzt und technisch veraltet war
Willi Paun hatte den Täter verfolgt hier
oben rechts in seinem Auto und mehrfach
erfolglos versucht die Polizei zu
erreichen er kann mich durch weil es
keine Notruf Weiterleitung gab und wurde
erschossen aus der heutigen sich zurück
betrachtet wenn hätte man sich gewünscht
dass die Umstellung erfolgt wäre das ist
in der Tat
von einem Fehler spricht er
Innenminister nicht nicolasko paoun ist
überzeugt dass ein Sohn leben würde wenn
er die Polizei erreicht hätte die hätte
ihm abgeraten den Täter zu verfolgen
hatten beamt im urausschuss bestätigt
hundert Prozent
wenn
jemand antwortet zum sein Telefon es
gibt keine Konsequenzen und keine
Gerechtigkeit ich bin enttäuscht und
traurig
auch ein Thema im U-Ausschuss warum war
der Notausgang im zweiten Tatort
versperrt was wohl für Hamza Kurtovic
und zeitnessa Haschemi zur Todesfälle
wurde juristischer Ermittlungen wurden
unter anderem mit der Begründung
eingestellt dass sie
verschlussverhältnisse unklar sein die
Aussage der Mannschaft ist widerlegt
worden hier Untersuchungsausschuss aber
trotzdem passiert nichts die Ermittlung
werden nicht wieder neu aufgenommen und
diese Frage stellen wir uns alle warum
nicht
wurde bei dem Attentat schwer verletzt
und kurz danach von der Polizei erstmal
nach seinem Ausweis gefragt bei der
Opferbetreuung gab es Defizite gegeben
diesen Fehler gestanden der
Innenminister ein und versprach den
Angehörigen künftig für Gespräche bereit
zu sein
im Januar starben zwei Menschen bei
einer Messerattacke in einem Zug bei
Brokstedt jetzt hat der Mordprozess
gegen den Angeklagten Palästinenser
begonnen zum Auftakt tritt der Mann vor
dem Landgericht Itzehoe die Tat ab die
Staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihm vor aus
Frust zugestochen zu haben in dem
Regionalzug wurden eine 17-Jährige und
ihren 19-Jährige Freund getötet vier
weitere Menschen wurden schwer verletzt
stellen Sie sich vor sie werden wegen
Mordes zu lebenslanger Haft verurteilt
obwohl sie unschuldig sind und dann nach
13 Jahren im Gefängnis kommt endlich der
Freispruch
so war das heute für Manfred genditzki
der Tod der alten Dame die er umgebracht
haben soll war offenbar ein Unfall es
sei ein steiniger Weg für den
Angeklagten gewesen den er mit
bewundernswerter Geduld gegangen sei
sagt die Richterin Petra Neubauer
Blumen und Umarmungen für manfreditsky
am Ende eines langen Kampfes und so
viele Jahre erlitt in den Unrechts
ja ich bin erleichtert dass endlich mal
die Wahrheit ans Licht gekommen ist
so weit geht es mir ganz gut aber ich
sag mal so im Grund zum Jubeln habe ich
nicht 14 Jahre sind Weg zum wiederholten
Mal hat sich ein Gericht mit seinem Fall
beschäftigt wieder ein Schicksalstag
diesmal mit gutem Ausgang für ihn
Manfred genditzki ist unschuldig Manfred
gennitzki wurde soeben freigesprochen er
hat die Verstorbenen nicht getötet das
Ende einer bizarren Geschichte in dieser
Wohnanlage in Rottach-Egern wird die
87-Jährige Liselotte Kostüm im Oktober
2008 tot in der Badewanne aufgefunden im
Obduktionsbericht weiß zunächst nichts
auf ein Fremdverschulden hin doch dann
erheben Ermittler plötzlich einen
Mordverdacht gegen Manfred gehen die Ski
der sich als Hausmeister um die alte
Dame gekümmert hatte trotz zweifelhafte
Indizien wird er angeklagt und zu
lebenslange Haft verurteilt Kritik heute
von den Verteidigern dass unzählige
Polizeiarbeit geleistet wurde die dann
von den Staatsanwaltschaft und
letztendlich von den Gerichten so
übernommen wird überzeugt haben das
Gericht neue Gutachten die zeigen dass
ein Sturz ein Unfall von Frau tüm hoch
wahrscheinlich war und dass sie später
gestorben sein muss als angenommen zu
einer Zeit für die Genitiv hatte die
mitfühlenden Worte von Richter Erl heute
für die Verteidigung ein wichtiges
Zeichen die Frau ist die erste die sich
beim Herrn genditzki entschuldigt hat
für etwas für das sie nichts konnte und
das rechnen wir natürlich hoch an
prohaft Tag stehen gentizki 75 Euro
Entschädigung zu macht rund 370.000 Euro
wiedergutmachen kann dass die verlorenen
Jahre sicher nicht
das mittelalterliche Nibelungenlied um
die Königstochter Brühen hielt und den
Mörder Hagen gilt als eine der
lieblingssagen der deutschen doch was
bringt uns diese Geschichte um Liebe
Verrat und macht noch heute die
Nibelungenfestspiele in Worms geben
Antwort das Drama sei konsequent
gegenwarts bezogen umgesetzt erstmals
übrigens von zwei Frauen als Autorin und
Regisseuren Christopher Heinze
[Musik]
einer Frau die im Laufe des Stücks immer
unabhängiger selbstbestimmter wird Gold
glitzern gibt Lena oceanowski die
Titelfigur Brünhild
ich
bin eine Walküre ich richte mich gegen
Unrecht und Kriegslust spürst aktuelle
Bezüge knallbunte Kostüme immer wieder
Videosequenzen dazu moderne Musik eine
ungewöhnliche Inszenierung wir sollten
eigentlich immer auf die alten Stoffe
mit einem neuen frischen Blick drauf
schauen und wir drehen die Geschichten
noch mal neu wir drehen die Figuren noch
mal neu und wir finden verschiedene
Universen in der männlichen Hauptrolle
Bekim Latifi als drachentöte Sigurd ein
laut sage beinahe unbesiegbarer der in
dieser Erzählung schon bald nicht mehr
kämpfen will im Namen des Menschsein
stehe ich hier
das nicht
die Aufführung springt wild zwischen
verschiedenen Zeitebenen und bricht mit
herkömmlichen Rollenbildern
im Grunde am Spiel das ganze Stück ja
quasi mit den Themen macht Eitelkeit
echoismus wie gehen wir miteinander um
also in einer ganz ganz starken ja
Aufmischung Hinterfragung auch von
Männer und Frauen Bildern die Geschichte
der Walküre Brünhild als visuelles
Feuerwerk zu sehen in den nächsten gut
zwei Wochen in Worms bei den Nibelungen
Festspielen im Schatten des Doms
tja jetzt zum Tennis zum Wimbledon da
ist alexandersverev der letzte deutsche
der im Einzel nicht raus ist ja genau
nach der maracorpatsch und Jule Niemeyer
sind heute damit die beiden letzten
Frauen ausgeschieden bei den Männern
Maximilian Marta auch raus
alexandersverev dagegen mit einem
souverän 3:1 Sieg gegen den Japaner
josuke Watanuki eine Runde weiter
nach erfolgreichen Spielen hat Alexander
Zverev sicher schon ausgelassene
gejubelt von dem weit den unbekannten
Japaner yuzukiwatanuki wird der
Hamburger wie auch die internationale
Tennis Fachwelt zwei spannende Sätze
lang überrascht doch Zverev gelingt es
trotz des verlorenen zweiten Satzes mit
nur wenig eigenen Fehlern den
sichtlichen nachlassenden 116 der
Weltrangliste mehr und mehr unter Druck
zu setzen
nach knapp zweieinhalb Stunden beendet
er das Match mit seinem 13 Ass und sieht
sich in der dritten Runde dem Italiener
Mario berettini gegenüber gegen den
bisher fünf Begegnungen viermal gewinnen
konnte
zweiter Wettkampftag bei den Finals den
Deutschen Meisterschaften in 18
Sportarten heute unter anderem in der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik ja und da
hat die Top Favoritinnen und
Weltmeisterin Daria favologe souverän
ihren Titel im Mehrkampf verteidigt
daja farfalomaje bleibt das Maß der
Dinge in der Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik
die 16-jährige Welt und Europameisterin
gewinnt mit großem Vorsprung an Reifen
Ball Keulen und Band vor Margarita
kosolow und Anna schinenko bereits ihren
dritten Titel hat Isabel Gosen
eingesammelt sie ist nicht perfekt
gestartet aber die Europameisterin ist
ihre Favoritenrolle über die 400 m
Freistil absolut gerecht geworden und
zeigt auch eine perfekte WM-Form
im Shop Hochsprung gelingt woanders ein
Höhenflug auf 5,82 m deutsche Jahres
Bestleistung und olympiaonorm mit nur
drei Versuchen verteidigt er seinen
deutschen Meistertitel vor olexes der 52
springt
und die morgigen Entscheidungen bei den
Finals live bei uns im ZDF zu sehen ab
10:15 Uhr zur Tour de France nach zwei
Tagen in den Pyrenäen heute eine
klassische flache von Monte Mason nach
bordeauger im massenspender nach 170 km
Jasper Philipsen und der dritte
Etappensieg des Bergers bester Deutscher
philharmahaus als Siebter
Gesamtführender im gelben Trikot bleibt
Titel Verteidiger Jonas winner aus
Dänemark
und morgen die achte Etappe wieder was
für die ganz Schnellen Fahrer mit einem
Schlusssprint bergauf
kuriosen und das bei der Hitze viel
trinken und im Schatten bleiben das wäre
ein Rad fürs Wochenende gibt viel Sonne
und Temperaturen bis 35 Grad die Details
hat gleich Christa Orben das heute
journal umziehen mit Christian Sievers
wir wünschen Ihnen ein schönes
Wochenende bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja zwischen dem Hoch EFI und
tiefquentin kommt jetzt die Zufuhr der
heißen Nordafrika Luft so richtig in
Schwung die Wolken hier über Frankreich
zeigen uns aber auch da hat sich noch
mal eine kleine Störung gebildet und die
bringt heute Nacht vom Südwesten bis in
die Mitte doch ein paar mehr Wolken
eventuell greift auch mal ein einzelnes
Gewitter in einzelne Schauer von
Frankreich auf den Südwesten über sonst
ist es sternenklar die Werte sinken
meist noch auf erfrischende 14 bis 10
Grad in den Ballungsräumen westlich des
Rheins und an der See geht's aber schon
nicht mehr unter 19 bis 17 Grad morgen
gibt's dann fast überall 30 Grad und
mehr bis 35 Grad sind im Westen
Südwesten möglich hier gibt's auch eine
starke Wärmebelastung etwas erträglicher
ist es in höheren Lagen und an der See
bei aufladigem östlichen Wind dazu
beginnt der Tag mit viel Sonne zur
Erinnerung mittags gibt's ja die
intensivste Sonnenstrahlung da wird am
meisten Sonnencreme gebraucht aber die
höchsten Temperaturen die erreichen wir
erst am späten Nachmittag frühen Abend
und so gibt's dann nachmittags auch
neben ein paar mehr Quellwolken im
westlichen südwestlichen Bergland
einzelne Hitze Gewitter aufgepasst aber
dann am Sonntag da gibt's Unwetter in
der Westhälfte Deutschlands dazu bis 37
Grad weiter eine starke Wärmebelastung
im Osten ist es noch sonnig und auch die
neue Woche geht mit Gewittern weiter von
Nordwesten wird es zwar etwas kühler
aber im Osten und Südosten bleibt es
weiter heißt tschüss